il y a même la merci de votre présence
nous sommes
[Applaudissements]
dans le cadre d'une mission que le Sénat
enfin que la commission des Lois du
Sénat plutôt s'est fixée
je rappelle que nous avons voté le texte
sur les valeurs de la République c'était
le 24 août 2021 se faire erreur de ma
part
ce texte a établi un certain nombre de
principes et de volonté de la part du
législateur
[Musique]
qui sont assez précis plusieurs natures
les rapporteurs de ce texte était Madame
Moustache Brignoud et Madame Verrien ici
présente la commission des lois a décidé
de procéder à une mission d'évaluation
de ce texte et donc c'est évidemment les
rapporteurs qui est dans le cadre de
leur pouvoir de contrôle et de suivi des
dossiers sont aujourd'hui en charge de
cette évaluation
voilà les raisons pour laquelle nous
avons demandé de venir et de répondre
aux questions qui seront faites par les
rapporteurs je vous renouvelle mes
excuses j'ai le devoir de quitter la
réunion parce que je dois rejoindre un
rendez-vous mais la présidente est
assurée par la première vice-présidente
Folco qui va maintenant organiser les
débats Merci à VOUS bonne continuation
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre je vais vous laisser d'abord
présenter votre propos luminaire et
ensuite je donnerai la parole à nos deux
rapporteurs et ensuite au commissaire de
la commission des lois qui sont présents
et qui souhaitent intervenir je vous
laisse la parole merci
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames les
rapporteurs mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs qui ont qui ont tenu jusqu'à
maintenant d'abord j'adresse mes
remerciements sincères à la commission
des lois pour me permettre de présenter
devant la Chambre haute ce point d'étape
de la mise en oeuvre de la loi du 24
août 2021 comportant le le respect des
principes de la République et de d'avoir
maintenu cette commission malgré
l'actualité chargée pour chacune et
chacun d'entre nous au cours de ces 20
dernières années nous avons été
confrontés en France à des pratiques
séparatistes de plus en plus affirmées
ce travail de SAP se déploie le plus
souvent de façon insidieuse dans toutes
les sphères de la société dans nos
quartiers populaires dans les services
publics dans le tissu associatif dans
les pratiques sportives mais aussi au
sein même de l'école de la République le
principe de laïcité au cœur de notre
pacte républicain subit de plus en plus
d'entors de contestations d'attaque
c'est un fait qui est aujourd'hui appuyé
d'éléments tangibles
lutter contre le séparatisme c'est
lutter contre un mouvement qui considère
qu'au nom de convictions religieuse ou
politiques ou au nom d'une cause d'une
cause pardon dont on considère qu'elle
transcende toutes les autres certaines
règles deviennent supérieures à celles
de la République et doivent prévaloir
sur ces derniers c'est important de
donner une définition parce que
finalement on en cherche souvent on
cherche souvent ce qui est séparatisme
ou pas le séparatisme c'est donc la
volonté de sortir y compris par la
violence de la communauté de valeur qui
nous réunit autour de la liberté de
l'égalité de la fraternité et de la
laïcité il faut avoir conscience de ce
qui se joue aujourd'hui et le regarder
en face de tels comportements mènent à
terme à la désintégration de l'idée même
de communauté nationale et mettre
profondément en danger le fonctionnement
de notre démocratie le président de la
République a parlé récemment de lutter
contre un processus de décibilisation et
c'est de ça qu'on parle dans le même
temps des groupuscules se radicalisent
de plus en plus et décide que la défense
de leurs causes justifie la violence
parfois même et on l'a vu récemment une
violence extrême
j'ai cité dans ces derniers mots l'ex
mouvement soulèvement de la terre qui a
été dissout en conseil des ministres le
21 juin dernier
notre position et je pense qu'elle est
évidemment partagée que c'est qu'aucune
cause aussi légitime soit-elle ne
justifie justifie pas dans une telle
violence dans un pays démocratique comme
la France ou la liberté d'expression et
la règle nous le savons notre pays a
subi ces derniers jours une vague de
violence inacceptable vous l'avez tous
subis nous avons nous n'avons pas et ça
a été dit par le ministre de l'Intérieur
juste avant moi le recul nécessaire pour
comprendre et qualifier les choses au
plus juste mais ce travail d'analyse
sera nécessaire pour déterminer s'il
s'agit finalement d'une nouvelle forme
de séparatisme et si les outils dont
nous disposons sont adaptés ou devront
évoluer pour y faire face
ce rappel nous conduit très
naturellement à l'objet de nos échanges
ce matin donc pourquoi cette loi et
quels sont les premiers et quelles en
sont les premiers résultats lors de son
discours mural de octobre 2020 le
président de la République a appelé à
défendre avec force les valeurs de la
République et à nous opposer au
développement du repli communautaire et
du séparatisme sur toutes ces formes une
stratégie globale de lutte contre le
séparatisme on a découlé elle visait à
en trois points entraver toutes les
initiatives contraires au fondement de
notre République à amplifier l'ensemble
des actions permettant de donner corps à
l'égalité des chances sur les
territoires et accompagner la
structuration de l'islam de France face
aux dérives des extrémistes de
l'islamisme
jusqu'à lors dans le dans le triangle
séparatisme en bas du ce qu'on appelle
le bas du spectre
radicalisation puis terrorisme nos
forces étaient principalement
concentrées sur ce qu'on appelle le haut
du spectre c'est-à-dire la lutte contre
le terrorisme et la radicalisation et
c'était bien normal avec la loi du 24
août 2021 l'État en fait s'est donné les
moyens de s'attaquer à au bas du spectre
au bas de la pyramide et à la racine du
problème le séparatisme qui nourrit bien
évidemment les individus radicalisés qui
eux-mêmes nourrissent le terrorisme sans
qu'évidemment tous les individus
séparatistes ne deviennent des
terroristes mais il faut dire que tous
ceux qui arrivent en haut de la pyramide
sont souvent
issus de ça
donc réglementation des cultes éducation
sport lutte contre la haine en ligne
cette loi nous a permis de changer
d'échelle et finalement il s'est sans
doute le plus important on y reviendra
de désinhiber l'administration et de lui
donner des outils pour s'attaquer à ce
qui tout ce qui peut donner de l'air au
séparatisme le financement des
associations on y reviendra
l'instruction en famille on y reviendra
également les écoles privées hors
contrat
donc je parlais tout à l'heure d'un
quand j'ai commencé d'un point d'étape
et non pas d'un bilan c'était l'objectif
de cette réunion parce qu'en fait on
manque et j'y reviendrai de recul sur un
certain nombre d'éléments parce que
c'est les outils qui sont mis en place
par cette loi et je remercie évidemment
les parlementaires qui nous ont adopté
les outils sont extrêmement puissants
mais tous n'ont pas encore été mis en
oeuvre pour des raisons diverses sur
lesquelles je reviendrai nous disposons
désormais donc
du résultat du contentieux sur le
contrat d'engagement républicain j'y
reviendrai également
donc on a maintenant un avis
un jugement favorable pour la mise en
place de ce CER on avait on a des
associations qui avaient jusqu'au 30
juin pour déclarer leur qualité
culturelles on a des déclarations de
financement étrangers qui sont en train
de monter en puissance bref on a tout un
tas de parties de cette loi qui sont
finalement encore en train d'être mis en
œuvre le premier véritable acquis de la
loi CRP est à chercher finalement dans
l'évolution des mentalités nous assumons
aujourd'hui et publiquement y compris de
combattre celles et ceux qui veulent
s'en prendre à notre bien le plus sacré
et nous les combattons aujourd'hui avec
les armes du droit
avec détermination bien évidemment et
sans naïveté à l'issue de cette première
année déjà et c'est un point positif
l'ensemble des textes d'applications de
la loi ont été pris c'est pas toujours
le cas quelques mois après le l'adoption
d'une loi là c'est le cas il s'agissant
d'un texte de plus de 100 articles c'est
suffisamment rare je crois pour être
souligné leur mise en oeuvre
encore inégale ça va de mieux en mieux
mais tu es encore inégal entre les
territoires et c'est pas forcément les
territoires qui sont qui ont le plus de
problématiques de séparatisme qui sont
le plus en avance et ceux qui au
contraire en ont le moins qui sont le
plus en retard c'est malheureusement
encore inégal inégal d'un point de vue
géographique
je vous donne quelques éléments chiffrés
dans la dans la sphère éducative parce
que on le sait bien et j'y reviendrai
sans doute sur les questions de laïcité
la cible principale des réseaux dont on
parle c'est notre jeunesse donc
évidemment ça ça rentre principalement
par ce biais là donc s'agissant de
l'instruction en famille grâce au
passage de régime du régime de
déclaration un régime d'autorisation le
nombre de total d'enfants instruits en
famille au plan national a baissé de
près de 30% par rapport à l'année
scolaire précédente les instances
départementales chargées de la
prévention de l'évitement scolaire sont
désormais tout opérationnel je pense que
ça c'est un élément important qui nous
permet de ne plus avoir de trous dans la
raquette on a on est capable aujourd'hui
grâce aux liens qui est fait dans chaque
département entre les caisses
d'allocations familiales les communes
les rectorats de savoir exactement de
connaître exactement tous les enfants et
de voir s'ils ne sont pas scolarisés la
possibilité pour un pour un préfet
pardon de fermer administrativement un
établissement privé hors contrat porte
déjà ses fruits puisque sur 47
établissements ciblés 5 ont fermé 4
écoles clandestiques clandestine ont été
fermées par arrêté préfectoral grâce à
la loi crpr depuis l'adoption de la loi
du 24 août 2021 onze dissolutions
administratives ont été prononcées à
l'encontre d'associations ou de
groupements de fait adhérents à
l'idéologie la miss radical ou à une
idéologie extrémiste provoquant ou
organisant des activités violentes
violentes grâce à la refonte par la loi
CRP des motifs permettant de prononcer
une telle mesure de police
administrative à travers la loi CRP nous
avons également souhaité accroître la
transparence de la vie associative des
cultes et de leur financement je citerai
ici trois dispositions importantes qui
ont été prises et qui fonctionnent
l'instauration du contrat d'engagement
républicain et j'imagine qu'on va y
revenir préalable à toute subvention
publique c'est vrai que sur ce
dispositif on a on manque un peu de
recul puisqu'on a eu la décision du
Conseil d'État il y a quelques jours et
que c'était difficile d'être
à 100% sur la mise en place d'un
dispositif dans l'attente d'un jugement
administratif qui aurait pu remettre en
cause le dispositif
l'argent l'argent qui est le nerf de la
guerre
les préfets disposent désormais d'un
pouvoir de contrôle et de dissolution
des fautes des fonds de dotation qui
sont les principaux vecteurs des
mouvements des mouvements islamistes des
fonds de dotations en 2022 4 fonds de
dotation ainsi l'objet d'une mesure de
suspension et quatre procédures de
dissolution sont également engagées
néanmoins et on y reviendra après 18
mois de pratique on constate déjà sans
doute des axes d'amélioration sur le
sujet pour donner au préfet des moyens
d'action renforcés sur les fonds de
dotation nous avons aussi rendu
obligatoire le fait de déclarer pour
tout association exerçant un culte les
financements qu'elle reçoit directement
ou indirectement de l'étranger ça nous
donne quand même des informations
extrêmement précieuses et pour compléter
une question qui qui je n'en doute pas
arrivera on a aussi commencé des
contrôles sur ceux qui n'ont pas déclaré
ces financements étrangers qui nous
permettent aussi d'une part de
déclencher un certain nombre de
procédures et d'autre part d'avoir des
informations précieuses précieuses cette
mesure est entrée en vigueur le 25 avril
2022 la loi cerper a par ailleurs
conformé conforté par dans le principe
de laïcité notamment dans les services
publics le déférer laïcité qui nous a
permis d'éviter que les pucines piscine
municipales de la piscine municipale de
Grenoble de Vienne
un lieu de un haut lieu de la baignade
en burkini on a développé plus de 2000
référents laïcité qui ont été nommés
dans les différentes administrations on
continue dans les trois fonctions
publiques on ne sait donner l'objectif
en 2025 d'arriver à 100% des agents
publics qui seront formés au principe de
laïcité
on a déjà 130 000 agents qui ont déjà
été formés à l'éducation nationale plus
40000 dans les autres administrations
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
avant de conclure je souhaite préciser
que contrairement à ce qui a été souvent
dit la loi CRP n'est pas un texte contre
les cultes et vous le savez bien ni
contre un culte en particulier ou contre
la liberté d'associations ou contre je
ne sais quoi c'est d'abord et avant tout
une loi de protection pour nos
concitoyens la protection de nos valeurs
et de nos principes républicains la
protection de notre cohésion nationale
la protection des cultes eux-mêmes
contre les ingérences la protection de
l'idéal associatif contre tout
dévoiement et la protection de la
dignité de la personne humaine lorsque
le législateur a introduit le déférer
laïcité c'est d'abord pour renforcer le
principe de laïcité de neutralité dans
les services publics locaux lorsqu'il a
institué le contrat d'engagement
républicain c'est pour éviter que des
structures séparatistes ne bénéficient
d'argent public lorsqu'il instaure le
délit de séparatisme c'est pour protéger
les élus et les agents publics contre
les menaces ou les violences comme on a
pu les voir ces derniers jours lorsque
l'instruction en famille est mieux
encadrée c'est pour éviter les dérives
et protéger les enfants c'est pourquoi
avec le ministre de l'Intérieur et des
Outre-mer on a un objectif assez clair
c'est que l'ensemble du territoire se
mobilise de manière égale pour donner
tout effectivement aux nouveaux outils
qui ont été mis en place par cette loi
crpr et c'est le message que nous avons
délivré d'une part par circulaire
d'autre part à l'oral à l'ensemble des
préfets avec le ministre de l'Intérieur
voilà simplement
finir par pour vous dire que
du territoire d'où je viens j'ai craint
dans les dernières années de perdre mon
appartenance à la République et je pense
qu'on a intérêt à continuer à
transmettre la fierté d'appartenir à la
République et je pense que cette loi
nous donne pour la découpe pour la
découvrir et pour la mettre en oeuvre
des outils particulièrement précieux
pour défendre la République et je pense
que quand on aura mis en oeuvre
l'ensemble du de l'éventail qu'elle nous
permet on aura des outils extrêmement
puissants
voilà je vous remercie merci madame la
ministre je vais laisser la parole à
nous rapporteur qui souhaite commencer
madame le stage bélier oui merci merci
mamie merci de m'avoir Président je vais
commencer parce que moi je dois partir à
19h15 donc je suis désolé c'est vrai
qu'on a les emplois du temps un peu
quand d'abord avant de prendre la parole
sur le texte je voulais à titre
personnel vous remercie vous
personnellement mesdames parce que je
vous connais pas vraiment mais je
connais votre engagement sur ce sujet je
suis assez critique généralement sur le
gouvernement envers le gouvernement sur
parfois les combats qu'il mènent sur
tous ces sujets mais je connais le vôtre
et je voulais le souligner ici et vous
en remercie voilà
alors sur ce sujet juste faire un tout
petit peu un historique avec ma collègue
finalement nous avons eu tes rapporteur
de ce texte je voulais juste rappeler
qu'il a pas été voté au Sénat la CMP n'a
pas été conclusie ça a été très rapide
la CMP je me rappelle très bien
parce que ce texte il est pas allé aussi
loin que nous l'aurions souhaité juste
une petite parenthèse il y a vraiment
des sujets dont on a parlé récemment qui
n'aurait pas eu lieu si nous avions si
le gouverne l'époque avait accepté un
certain nombre de chances que nous avons
que nous avions écrites dans ce texte ça
aurait protecté encore davantage la
République j'en suis convaincu mais bon
on va pas refaire l'histoire c'est comme
ça aujourd'hui on fait exactement le
bilan d'une loi qu'on a d'un texte qu'on
n'a pas voté mais sur lequel nous avons
toutes les deux en tout cas beaucoup
travaillé avec notre énergie et notre
fibre républicaine je dirais juste une
petite un petit rappel aussi faut aussi
se rappeler que ce texte il est venu
juste après une commission d'enquête que
la commission des lois portait
commission d'enquête sur l'islamisme et
comment le combattre un sujet sur lequel
on avait été très très loin sur lequel
on avait fait une quarantaine de
propositions je crois certaines ont été
reprises d'autre part bon voilà mais
souvent
si je dis ça c'est parce que
ce n'est pas un parti pris de dire il y
a les bons et les méchants c'est que
nous sommes convaincus comme vous l'avez
dit madame la ministre que notre
République est en danger quand on combat
pas voilà et que moi je suis élu de
banlieue depuis longtemps j'ai vu les
choses évoluées et tristement évolué
c'est pour ça que j'essaye de parfois
bousculer les lignes sur ce sujet alors
effectivement vous avez dit qu'il
fallait faire attention et qu'il fallait
lutter parce que il fallait faire
évoluer les mentalités avec une chose
essentielle qu'il faut préserver c'est
la laïcité vous l'avez dit et
malheureusement on est quand même assez
inquiète voir ce qui se passe et ce qui
grave de manière gravissime se passe
depuis quelques mois depuis quelques
mois on voit bien dans les écoles etc et
vous avez rappelé juste titre qui est en
moins de socles qu'il faut préserver
c'est l'école et le sport si nous
n'arrivons pas à préserver l'école et le
sport nous n'arriverons pas à préserver
les enfants de la République et les
enfants de la République ils n'ont pas
de couleur de peau ce sont les enfants
de la République et ils n'ont pas de
religion dans l'école ce sont les
enfants de la République ça il faut le
rappeler et vous avez bien fait de
rappeler alors moi je voulais revenir
sur deux trois j'ai deux trois petites
questions en particulier qui concerne
les associations effectivement le
contrat d'engagement républicain on a
abordé ce sujet avec les services qui
sont là aujourd'hui hier parce que comme
on a dû décaler tous nos agendas on a
fait comme on a pu vous et nous c'est
vrai que c'est un contrat qui a fait
débat qui m'ont posé évidemment pas de
souci moi je voulais savoir si
l'effectivement mais c'est peut-être un
peu tôt pour le dire parce que c'est
vrai qu'elle n'a que deux ans à peine
cette loi est-ce que toutes les
associations qui bénéficient de d'argent
public ont signé est-ce qu'elles ont
tous signé et proportionnellement si
elles n'ont pas tous signé combien en
ont déjà signé
est-ce que par exemple pour les scouts
ça leur a posé problème parce que c'est
un sujet qui avait été posé ici moi ce
qui ce qui m'intéresse aussi et la
conversation qu'on a eu hier m'interroge
c'est
si le contrat d'engagement républicain
c'est juste une case à cocher sur un
CERFA moi ça m'interroge sur
l'efficacité de ce contrat d'engagement
donc peut-être faudra-t-il le définir
autrement parce que cocher une case sur
un CERFA ça n'engage pas à grand chose à
mes yeux bon je l'ai dit hier c'est
voilà donc sur effectivement ce texte
qui devait permettre aussi de dissoudre
plus facilement des associations qui
portent atteinte à la République bon on
vous en avez parlé de quelques-unes
j'aimerais bien savoir combien
d'associations ont été dissoutes et même
bon alors évidemment c'est on a un temps
court et s'il y en a en cours bon voilà
et comment et quels outils et comment
vous avez pu arriver à cette dissolution
de ces associations qui portent un tas
aux valeurs de la République vous avez
parlé aussi
du déféré du déféré préfectoral moi je
voudrais savoir si tous les préfets ont
mis ces actions
en marche parce que c'est important
alors les préfets ont un rôle crucial à
jouer sur ce déféré préfectoral
évidemment je ne suis pas mon
interrogation c'est je suis pas sûr que
les préfets travaillaient trois
traitement avec les élus sur ce sujet ça
ça m'interroge beaucoup je pense que
parce que pourquoi je le dis c'est pas
que parce que il y a des élus qui sont
acteurs de la lutte contre ces
phénomènes de séparatisme et il y en a
qui sont moins je le dis clairement de
tout bord comme ça je suis très à l'aise
il y en a tout de tous les côtés de
l'échiquier politique et donc je pense
qu'il faut aussi peut-être alors c'est
peut-être un peu tôt mais il va falloir
peut-être que les préfets
bousculent un peu les choses
c'est-à-dire que il y a aussi des
exigences que notre pays doit avoir
enfin envers certains élus parce que
cette loi elle doit le permettre aussi
il me semble bon je pense que vous en
pensez mais il me semble
deux dernières petites questions sur les
lieux de culte en France
est-ce qu'on a une idée sur
la manière dont sont vraiment contre les
lieux de culte on a vu que certains
Youtubes étaient fermées trois mois six
mois parce qu'ils sont pas fermés
définitivement les lieux de culte ils
sont fermés lanières temporaire avec
parfois un objectif c'est de faire
partir l'imam qui est dans la mosquée
parce qu'effectivement il a des propos
qui sont pas
vraiment en lien avec le respect de la
République mais sur les lieux de culte
est-ce qu'on a réussi à avoir une
analyse objective ce qui se passe dans
ces études et est-ce qu'on les connaît
tous parce que c'est un peu la question
que que nous nous posons voilà je vais
arrêter de je vais laisser la parole à
ma collègue madame verrière et donc je
vais poursuivre merci madame la
Présidente et donc merci effectivement
madame la ministre d'être ici pour nous
permettre de poursuivre ce travail donc
l'un des objectifs affichés lors de la
loi du 24 août 2021 était d'amener
notamment le culte musulman dans sa
diversité a adopté le cadre de la loi 19
et de limiter le recours aux
associations créées sur le fondement de
la loi 1901 ou des associations mixtes
de 1907 alors comment la situation
a-t-elle évolué au cours des deux
dernières années
est-ce que là encore beaucoup de
nouveaux cultes éventuellement ce serait
inscrit pour pouvoir bénéficier de
défiscalisation puisqu'on sait que c'est
ce que permet la loi 1905 ensuite sur
les associations
là encore on avait pour éviter
on avait mis un contrôle des
associations enfin la loi mettait un
contrôle des associations tant pour leur
financement que pour éviter l'entrisme
et donc ça avait fait d'important débats
quels résultats est-ce qu'on a pu
obtenir et notamment le dispositif du
antipuce pour éviter qu'une association
éventuellement culturelle mais en
réalité culturelle ne puisse être prise
d'assaut et donc avoir ensuite le culte
des tournées
et enfin deux questions une qui était
effectivement revenue
la loi avial étant l'ayant enfin ayant
été en partie annulée c'était revenu
lors de cette loi de 2021 la lutte
contre la haine en ligne et
particulièrement contre la divulgation
d'informations personnelles le
harcèlement et les menaces pour des
motifs du coup tous les motifs mais
notamment des motifs religieux
est-ce que cette lutte a pu être
renforcée est-ce que vous avez pu faire
des choses en plus que on ne pouvait pas
faire avant et donc est-ce que vous avez
pu mi le mieux lutter et enfin une
question qui ne vous surprendra pas
venant de moi madame la ministre c'est y
a-t-il pour vous des menaces émergentes
en matière d'atteinte au principe de la
République particulièrement du côté des
dérives sectaires ou de nouvelles
spiritualités le cadre légal est
réglementaire actuel est-il suffisant
pour y faire face
merci mesdames madame la ministre je
vous laisse répondre à ces questions
merci madame la Présidente donc
effectivement un certain nombre
d'éléments de réponse d'abord sur sur
votre propos liminaire sur la question
de d'avoir de ne pas avoir voté toutes
les propositions je crois que l'idée de
ce point d'étape d'une part et d'autre
part de notre propre jugement notre
propre analyse sur la manière dont cette
loi peut être mise en oeuvre nous
permettra le cas échéant de proposer
nous ou ça viendra de d'initiatives
parlementaires des évolutions je crois
qu'il faut regarder les choses avec
beaucoup de pragmatisme un peu
d'humilité et et voir comment les choses
peuvent évoluer c'est notre vision des
choses pour pour reprendre sur une
question que vous abordez un peu plus
tard à la question du contrat
d'engagement républicain il y a une
question d'appropriation par les
collectivités locales du contrat
d'engagement républicain au-delà du fait
qu'on attendait nous d'avoir le jugement
du Conseil d'État il y a aussi une
question d'appropriation donc il y a
deux démarches à faire sur cette
question là en particulier mais c'est le
cas finalement sur beaucoup de d'aspects
de la loi il y a un point de formation
des collectivités locales donc
d'accompagnement fait par les services
de l'État et d'autre part de bilan que
je m'engage à faire à la fin de l'année
avec les réseaux l'AMF l'ADF pour voir
comment s'est mis en oeuvre quels sont
les problématiques qui rencontrent parce
que vous avez parlé d'une case à cocher
je me permets de répondre à cette
question là directement oui c'est une
case à cocher aujourd'hui et oui la
question peut se poser de savoir s'il
faut qu'on aille un peu plus loin et
s'il faut qu'on répète notamment les 7
obligations peut-être sans rentrer
forcément dans dans tout le lyrisme de
la rédaction du décret mais au moins les
7 points pour que chacun sache
exactement ce qu'il signe mais
la votre question c'est est-ce que tous
les toutes les toutes les associations
qui ont touché de l'argent public ont
signé oui puisque en fait tout
simplement pour la raison simple que
c'est que si elle coche pas la case elle
ne bénéficient pas d'argent public donc
très clairement oui 100% des des
associations qui ont touché de l'argent
public ont signé mais ils ont elles ont
coché une case donc la question de on se
la pose évidemment avec les services de
faire évoluer le CERFA c'est une vraie
question vous avez posé ensuite la
question de la de la laïcité
je voudrais vous dire que alors d'abord
enfin c'est pas forcément directement en
lien avec la loi CRP puisque en fait les
atteintes à la laïcité notamment à
l'école sont pas sont pas liés il y a
pas d'évolution dans la loi CRP par
rapport à ça
les juristes prudences sur la question
de l'école sont sans ambiguïté je vais
me permettre simplement d'en lire dans
lire une mais il y en a il y en a
plusieurs qui vont dans le même sens le
Conseil d'État a jugé que le port
systématique d'une longue jupe noire
couvrance en pantalon et d'un large bain
d'eau masquant une grande partie de ses
cheveux pouvait justifier la non-ré
intégration d'une élève donc et toutes
les juristes prudences vont dans ce
sens-là donc aujourd'hui les chefs
d'établissement qui sont concernés sont
totalement fondés à accepter enfin à
exclure ou à ne pas réintégrer une élève
qui serait concernée donc quelque part
il y a pas d'ambiguïté c'est simplement
l'application de la loi qui faut qu'il
nous faut améliorer ou qui nous faut
renforcer l'accompagnement des chefs
d'établissement et des enseignants qui
parfois il faut le dire ont peur parce
que ils sont menacés parce que voilà et
les enseignants de la même manière quand
on a eu un sondage récent qui prouve que
il y a près de 50% des enseignants qui
ne signalent pas les atteintes à la
laïcité c'est qu'on a on a un sujet on a
des axes d'amélioration sur sur ce sujet
là
mais qui sont pas directement en lien
avec la loi CRP
idem sur sur la le sport vous avez parlé
de ces deux sujets là la jurisprudence
et et je m'en félicite du Conseil d'État
sur les jobus est extrêmement importante
essentielle
donc aujourd'hui on a la possibilité
pour des raisons plutôt de d'ailleurs de
de vivre ensemble de permettre dans les
règlements intérieurs des fédérations
sportives d'empêcher le port de
vêtements de marqueur religieux donc ça
c'est important donc ça veut dire que
dans l'école et dans le sport puisque
c'est les deux les deux les deux
secteurs que vous avez évoqués on a
finalement les outils juridiques
aujourd'hui il s'agit plutôt d'une mise
en œuvre
vous m'avez demandé combien
d'associations dissoute je l'avais dit
dans mon propos liminaire mais cinq en
2000 en 2021 4 en 2022 3 en 2023
dissoute avec une procédure avec un
contradictoire avec enfin toute une
procédure qui est assez lourde on l'a vu
dans le cadre de la dissolution des
soulèvements de la terre qui avait
d'autres problèmes que de problématiques
de séparatisme mais en tout cas
clairement les choses sont faites de
manière assez assez complète
les lieux de culte donc les lieux de
culte aujourd'hui nous n'avons la
possibilité légale uniquement de
suspendre pour 6 mois pour des raisons
de terrorisme ou de trois mois pour des
raisons de
[Musique]
séparatisme enfin de discours de haine
l'idée c'est de dire que en fait cette
période de suspension elle permet tout
simplement de traiter l'individu toxique
de sortir l'individu toxique parce qu'en
fait souvent c'est lié puisque vous
parliez des mosquées c'est lié à un imam
qui est qui porte un certain nombre de
propos
à propos haineux
séparatiste etc donc finalement l'idée
c'est pas de fermer définitivement parce
que finalement souvent c'est pas la
mosquée dans son ensemble qui pose
problème c'est un individu et donc la
suspension et c'est ce qui fait d'un
pardon dans plusieurs cas permet de
traiter ces sujets-là vous m'avez
ensuite passé parlé l'importance de
basculement de 1901 à 1905 ça commence
sérieusement mais c'est insuffisant on a
de plus en plus d'associations qui
basculent mais très objectivement ça va
nous demander un accompagnement plus
fort pour accompagner les associations
et évoluer pour des raisons
principalement administratives
principalement de d'accompagnement
administratif donc voilà je ça commence
ça va dans le bon sens et pour répondre
à la deuxième partie sur la question de
la loi anti-pouche toutes les
associations qui ont basculé en 1905 du
coup se satisfont de cette disposition
un type punch qui finalement les
sécurise plus qu'autre chose donc je
pense qu'effectivement c'est un des
éléments
qui leur permet également de basculer
vous m'avez posé ensuite la question du
renforcement des moyens sur la lettre
sur la sur la N en ligne c'est plus de
équivalentes en plein qui ont été créés
sur le sujet avec objectivement et vous
connaissez sans aucun doute la
plateforme Pharos des des efficacités
dans le traitement de ces sujets là qui
est assez remarquable pour l'avoir vu
sur un certain nombre de sujets là le
ministre de l'Intérieur vous le savez à
donner des consignes très claires sur la
question des menaces sur les policiers
dans le cadre des événements récents et
ça réellement été utile les outils qui
ont été créés sont réellement réellement
utiles et pour finir sur votre dernière
question qui était la question sur les
dérives sectaires on est parfois à la
limite sur ces sujets là on a un certain
nombre d'organisations qui à la base
sont
ou d'ultra gauche ou d'ultra-droite qui
finalement un certain nombre de
groupuscules finissent par ressembler
parfois à des organisations à caractère
sectaire et certaines de ces
organisations sont suivies par la
mivilud on le sait
ça peut être des structures évangéliques
ça peut être enfin on a on a d'à peu
près tout dans les dérives sectaires et
vous le savez bien donc là on manque
clairement d'outils on a fait les les
assises des de lutte contre les dérives
sectaires en mars dernier on a le plan
global de lutte contre les rives
sectaires qui va être présenté dans les
prochains jours on est en train de le
finaliser et on a une un projet de loi
qui va qui va être présenté dans les
prochaines semaines sur la partie pénale
parce que on manquait d'outils sur la
partie pénale en matière de dérive
secteur projet de loi assez court
puisque c'est cet article mais qui
permet de remplir les trous qui avait
dans la raquette sur ces sujets là parce
qu'on voit bien et on on a des sujets
très précis qui sont aujourd'hui
regardés par la mivilud sur lesquels on
se rend compte qu'on n'a pas forcément
tous les outils aujourd'hui pour
permettre de lutter efficacement voilà
j'espère que j'ai répondu à vos
questions merci Madame la Ministre
madame les rapporteurs vous souhaitez
compléter vos demandes oui juste pour
compléter parce que c'est vrai que
l'analyse que nous faisons tous et
probablement vous aussi madame la
ministre c'est que
le gouvernement l'État c'est doté de
petites techniques en fait d'outils
techniques donc dont on avait besoin non
mais clairement voilà qui vont à court
moyen et long terme porter leurs fruits
avec probablement des choses qui vont se
caler s'améliorer etc le problème de
fond il est plus grave que celui-là en
fait et et probablement que c'est pas
cette loi là qui règle le problème de
fond je pense qu'on est assez d'accord
toutes les deux pour dire ça c'est qu'il
y a il y a vraiment
quand vous disiez tout à l'heure une
évolution des mentalités c'est une
évolution de prise de conscience
collective partout partout de ce que
nous entre guillemets subissons nous
républicains forcené j'ai envie de dire
et et c'est vraiment pas uniquement ce
texte qui réglera ça je pense qu'on est
conscient il nous en étant toutes les
deux consciente dès le départ c'est que
il y a des outils il y a des règles
qu'on écrit mais malheureusement ça ne
suffira pas parce qu'on voit bien que
depuis que ce texte est sorti il y a un
certain nombre de choses qui ont empiré
et qui ne se sont pas améliorés il faut
juste savoir l'objectivité de le dire
voilà c'était juste ça et c'est pas une
critique ils avaient de vous ou vous
avez des services c'est fondamentalement
notre pays doit prendre les choses
je dois prendre ce sujet-là prononce sur
d'autres volets et avec d'autres outils
madame la ministre
je suis complètement d'accord de toute
façon c'est pas une loi qui qui règle
les problèmes de société fondamentaux
qui sont là et puis
j'avais la discussion avec le ministre
de l'intérieur on a parfois l'impression
je l'ai dit quand j'étais auditionné sur
le sur le fond Marianne on a
l'impression que parfois de vider
l'océan la petite cuillère mais si on
s'arrête c'est pire et et je j'ai
assisté à des à des clients à des
cellules locales dans les dans les
préfectures de lutte contre l'islam
radical très franchement on a maintenant
des outils extrêmement puissants quand
on est capable sur un sur un écran
d'avoir un schéma avec l'ensemble des
structures écoles associations
financement qui finalement brosse un
état des liens de tous ordres et qu'on
est capable d'entraver chacune de ces
parties parce que c'est ça
qu'aujourd'hui nous offre la loi c'est
c'est honnêtement d'une puissance assez
forte et et quand elle utiliser à plein
cette loi elle permet de faire des
choses et il y a des préfets qui
l'utilisent parfaitement bien et pour
lesquels c'est d'une efficacité
remarquable aujourd'hui on a
objectivement pas tout pas tout pris en
main et ça ça demande encore à demande
encore à être à être amélioré mais en
tout cas c'est de beaux outils la loi
suffit pas je suis d'accord avec vous de
toute façon il y a il y a sans doute on
a beaucoup parlé de l'école mais il y a
quelque chose qui doit se passer à
l'école pour pour un une évolution aussi
des mentalités et pour une évolution de
l'adhésion aux valeurs de la République
et c'est pas dans cette loi qu'on va le
qu'on va le faire mais en tout cas ça
nous donne des outils
juste une dernière réflexion c'est vrai
que
l'association c'est aussi le cœur du
sujet parce que vous venez de dire
qu'effectivement
sur un écran on peut mettre mais je peux
aller plus loin que vous plus loin que
ça encore sur un écran vous regardez
tous les réseaux entre les associations
qui font du caritatif des associations
qui font le voyage des associations
enfin il y a c'est une économie
parallèle institutionnalisée par des
associations dans certains départements
et dans certaines villes et c'est là
qu'il faut qu'on mette le nez parce
qu'on s'aperçoit que voilà moi un peu
travaillé sur ce sujet on s'aperçoit que
des associations my totalement une
commune sur tous les secteurs de la vie
de la société ça va de l'école ça va du
soutien scolaire ça va sur le soutien
caritatif le voyage enfin tout et on
s'aperçoit que ces associations créent
un système parallèle au nom d'une
religion et c'est ça qui est très
inquiétant vraiment et c'est sur ça
qu'il faut que nous nous et que nous
écrivions les choses voilà et très
sincèrement sur les écoles hors contrat
vraiment il va falloir être très très
acteur très actif pourquoi je le dis
c'est que les écoles hors contrat elles
forment les elles ont des enfants qui
sont les adultes de demain et moi je
pense essentiellement aux petites filles
je dis pas que les garçons ne
m'intéresse pas madame la ministre mais
les petites filles c'est quand même une
vraie inquiétude dans les écoles hors
contrat si vous allez si vous passez à
côté d'école hors contrat je ne donnerai
pas des départements parce que je ne
veux pas stigmatiser les petites filles
à la maternelle sont entièrement voilées
vraiment c'est une réalité c'est une
réalité donc voilà les écoles hors
contrat il faut vraiment vraiment s'y
atteler alors pas en 3 jours pendant 6
mois mais c'est un vrai sujet ces écoles
sont hors de la République mais c'est
pas uniquement alors sur les programmes
j'en parle pas mais c'est sur le devenir
de ces petites filles et de ces garçons
çons qu'on élève dans la fille est un
pur la fille n'existe pas la fille c'est
ça et ce sont les adultes de demain et
s'il y en a 10 et si on a sens c'est
toujours 10 ou 100 de trop voilà et on
voit bien mais nous sommes responsables
collectivement de tout ça ça date pas
d'hier j'ai l'honnêteté intellectuelle
de le lire mais vraiment aujourd'hui on
est au cœur du sujet vraiment
madame la ministre ensuite je donnerais
la parole à Madame Gatel merci sur les
associations je pense que c'est là qu'on
a sans doute la marge de de travail la
plus importante encore une fois pour les
raisons que j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure
il y a tout un travail à faire tout en
gardant la richesse ne donne de notre
dispositif associatif de liberté de
voilà il faut c'est toujours c'est
toujours l'équilibre compliqué qu'on
doit trouver sur Oui oui
j'ai vu les réseaux donc sur les écoles
hors contrat on en a fermé 5 c'est c'est
déjà ça et au-delà de ça on a des
contrôles qui sont de plus en plus
importants et vous avez parlé des
inopiner c'est ce que c'est et et
je vais aller un petit peu au-delà des
décolores contrats pour parler de
l'instruction en famille sur laquelle il
y a énormément de de polémiques et je
l'entends parce que la très grande
majorité des enfants qui sont dans le
cadre d'un enseignement d'une
instruction en famille pose pas de
problème sauf que dans le cadre des
contrôles qu'on a effectué dans le cadre
de l'instruction en famille et bien on a
trouvé des choses on a trouvé notamment
et parce que 100% des enfants qui
suivent une instruction en famille ont
été contrôlées mais on a trouvé des
enfants qui regardent qui apprennent
dans le cadre de support de cours où les
enfants sont sans visage ou voilés
[Musique]
de la République et on a avec ces outils
là maintenant la possibilité de les voir
parce que parfois ils sont et souvent
ils sont hors de la République mais ils
touchent des allocations familiales et
donc on le voit avec le lien avec la CAF
madame la minou moi j'ai trois points le
premier concerne les écoles privées hors
contrat pour lesquelles j'avais beaucoup
travaillé avec Monsieur Blanquer la loi
prévoyait avant même de nouvelles
dispositions sur les écoles privées hors
contrat un contrôle qui s'il était
considéré comme insuffisant générale
deuxième contrôle sachant que souvent
ces écoles sous un statut associatif
l'association concernée devait apporter
des réponses très argumentées on
remarques qui étaient faites et si le
deuxième contrôle était jugé
insatisfaisant on pouvait alors procéder
à des mesures que je qualifierais
disciplinaire si je puis moi j'aimerais
que le ministre éducation nationale nous
fournit ou par votre intermédiaire ou
directement le nombre de contrôles qui
sont effectués dans l'année le nombre
d'avis d'insuffisance
la chute ce premier contrôle et le
nombre de deuxième contrôle qui sont
faits puisque la loi le prévoit depuis
fort longtemps et ce que l'on avait
constaté c'est que si des premiers
contrôles étaient faits les deuxièmes
n'étaient jamais fait et que nous avions
aussi un problème de formation des
inspecteurs
à ces contrôles y compris dans
l'éducation en famille puisque il y a de
manière enfin on va dire naturel une
appréhension très forte de la part de
l'école privée hors contrat ou des
parents d'un contrôle puisque
ces personnes on va falloir l'impression
que le contrôle est fait à charge alors
même que ça n'est pas le cas mais que
puisque la pédagogie est libre c'est le
principe même de l'école privée est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui il y a encore
d'enseignant qui est formé comme cela
était fait dans l'académie de Versailles
où il y avait un guide de un guide du
contrôle il faut que les inspecteurs
soient sécurisés donc où on en est
là-dessus deuxième question vous avez
parlé de la décision
[Musique]
supra sur les hits jabus moi je cette
décision me réjouit mais je me permets
de penser qu'elle est fragile ce que je
pense que son argumentation juridique
qui aboutit un résultat
qu'on apprécie peut quand même je crois
souffrir aujourd'hui d'une contestation
qui ne nous met pas à l'abri de réelles
difficultés d'un jugement qui
contredirait celui-là et qui amènera du
coup à ouvrir le robinet et donc de ce
fait mon troisième point porc sur ce que
vous allez dire juste titre vraiment
c'est pas une critique c'est que
l'interprétation de la loi
à l'école
est soumise à l'appréciation de
l'enseignant et du directeur et
sincèrement je pense qu'aujourd'hui on
ne peut pas
laisser un enseignant ou un directeur ou
improviseur tout seul pour apprécier
cela parce qu'on le positionne dans un
contexte très difficile puisqu'il en
proximité c'est comme un maire qui a
géré une séquence de violence il est
tout seul
un moment il y a une domination de la
personne qui est en face et que le libre
arbitre
on va dire de l'enseignant ou du
directeur la peur qui fait que le
politiquement correct font que on lâche
n'ont pas que les gens soient là mais on
peut pas demander une personne seule de
porter l'application des lois de la
République quand on est dans un contexte
on est en grande faiblesse et que au
Sénat moi j'ai longtemps quand on
parlait du port du voile moi j'ai
longtemps
voté pour dire que autoriser des mères
de famille à porter le voile pour des
sortir scolaires c'était une manière de
ne pas les éloigner de c'est à dire de
considérer que
elle pouvait s'intégrer aux activités à
l'école donc on les perdait pas de vue
de la réplique aujourd'hui moi je vous
avoue être sur une position
totalement différent est-ce que pour
avoir discuter comme beaucoup d'entre
nous avec des enseignants et des
directeurs moi j'entends les enseignants
qui me disent mais madame la sénatrice
comment moi j'expliquais une mère de
famille qui est venu faire un atelier
peinture dans les locaux de l'école
qu'elle vient sans voile une demi-heure
après on prend le bus on part au musée
et que je peux la laisser porter avant
comment je peux expliquer ça des enfants
comment je tiens le truc et que
sincèrement moi je pense que à un moment
il y a comment dire aucun
nostracisme aucune condamnation mais je
pense sincèrement que la loi de la
République elle doit être efficace pour
être efficace elle doit être simple et
pas simplifier et que donc moi je
réinterroge le gouvernement sur ces deux
dispositions c'est à dire comment on
fait l'école pour considérer que c'est
une tenue enigieuse ou que ça ne l'est
pas on voit bien comment ça évolue
on passe du grand voile à autre chose
voilà et on a aujourd'hui des abeilles
parce que ce serait la mode et puis il y
aura des abeilles à républicaines comme
des maillots de bain républicain mais un
peu la connotation fortement religieuse
voilà moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui on ne
peut plus être dans la subtilité la
finesse ce qu'on met en danger des
personnes et du coup on entrave
l'application de la loi de la République
j'ai conscience de la gravité de mon
propos
merci Madame Gatel madame la ministre
merci mais là c'est la triste un certain
nombre de réponses sur les sur les
établissements privés hors contrat
les questions que vous posez j'ai pas
les réponses je pense qu'il faut qu'il y
ait une présentation spécifique
peut-être de l'éducation nationale j'en
parlerai à mon collègue pour qu'il vous
fasse un point précis à la commission
culture voilà le cas échéant vous
croisiez pour créer une présentation
spécifique des dispositifs et des
contrôles qui sont fait sur sur ces
sujets là
sur la question de l'atteinte à la
laïcité vous avez vous avez évoqué
plusieurs points d'abord le fait de ne
pas laisser seul les enseignants et les
chefs d'établissement
c'est pas le cas c'est pas le cas
d'abord parce que les circulaires qui a
été envoyée par le ministre de
l'Intérieur et moi-même d'une part
d'autre part que le ministre de
l'éducation nationale on a fait une
autre en assurant de la protection
fonctionnelle de chacun des des acteurs
concernés je suis d'accord c'est c'est
sans doute parfois insuffisant mais
on va pas mettre un policier à côté de
chaque enseignant c'est pas non plus la
solution donc
s'il y en a d'autres voilà mais mais
aujourd'hui la loi la loi elle est quand
même sur la question de la de la laïcité
à l'école finalement extrêmement claire
la loi plus les différentes
jurisprudences quand on regarde tous les
marqueurs je les dis tout à l'heure avec
la jurisprudence sur la Baya aujourd'hui
les les enseignants les chefs
d'établissement qui font le choix
d'exclure une élève qui porte la Baya
sont dans leurs droits
sont dans leurs droits la loi leur
permet et les jurisprudences sont
extrêmement claires donc la question
elle est pas enfin pardon mais la
question elle est pas juridique elle est
pas législative elle est de la de la de
la peur tout simplement et de la manière
dont on accompagne donc ça c'est plus
une question d'organisation de l'école
et de la manière dont elle évolue
sur la question en particulier des des
accompagnatrices scolaires vous l'avez
évoqué c'est un sujet c'est un sujet le
gouvernement applique la loi la loi ne
prévoit pas aujourd'hui
cette obligation pour les
accompagnatrices scolaires et et
alors c'est
oui oui non mais alors attention juste à
une chose c'est qu'il y a un avis du
Conseil d'État de 2013 qui dit qui dit
que même si on faisait évoluer la loi on
pourrait pas mettre ça en place
l'enfant les parents le parent il est il
est très clair l'argument pour le
gouvernement je sais que c'est pas
facile parce que c'est un débat qu'on a
eu deux fois au Sénat
le parent il confie son enfant à l'école
en gros de 8h30 à 16h30 or contre
cantine l'école c'est ça et que ce soit
dans les murs ou les murs c'est l'école
donc c'est facile d'avoir cet argument
on n'a pas voulu l'entendre cet argument
voilà on confie son gamin à 8h30 à
l'école de la République et jusqu'à
16h30 c'est l'école de la République
qu'on fasse des activités dans les murs
ou en les murs c'est un argument
tellement simple à utiliser qui serait
très facilitateur c'est exactement ce
que dit Madame Gatel c'est un sujet
qu'on a eu deux fois un débat qu'on a eu
deux fois on l'a voté deux fois ici
aujourd'hui avec ce qui se passe le
goaland ferait bien d'écouter le Sénat
sur ce que le Sénat dit depuis 2017 sur
ce sujet là et je vous assure moi je
suis élu de banlieue et je l'aime ma
banlieue et il faut arrêter qu'on nous
dise que les enfants font plusieurs
scolaires parce que au cinéma m'envoie
les enfants pas il y a aucune il y a
aucun école ou 100% des mamans sont
voilées et puis arrêtons de parler des
mamans il y a aussi des papas et les
papas ils peuvent aussi faire les
sorties scolaires donc voilà c'est un
vrai sujet parce que c'est un marqueur
de la République c'est exactement ce que
dit Madame Gadenne quand on ouvre les
digues on rentre dedans donc voilà et on
en est là aussi voilà
mais je suis une parenthèse que je fais
parce que c'est des débats qu'on a eu
ici et ma collègue elle a elle-même
évolué sur le sujet parce qu'elle voit
que quand on ouvre des digues regardez
vous en sommes ici trois ou quatre ans
après les débats qu'on a eu au Sénat
c'est de c'est pire encore voilà bon de
toute façon ce qui est très clair et et
là-dessus on est on est je crois tous en
phase c'est que la situation a évolué et
que on doit s'adapter et que donc et que
donc imaginer des évolutions à cette loi
là et à d'autres
je crois qu'il faut fermer aucune porte
très clairement et c'est pas enfin
pardon mais c'est pas moi qui ai mis en
place la tenue commune à l'école dans la
activités que je préside qui vais vous
dire le contraire donc effet évidemment
je crois qu'il y a des choses qui faut
qu'on réfléchisse différemment je sais
pas si c'est ça la solution on a on a on
a une on a un dispositif mais la laïcité
à la française elle est tout le temps on
est tout le temps dans le cadre d'un
combat ou ceux qui combattent cette ce
principe là sont tout le temps en train
de chercher les failles donc c'est à
nous aussi d'être en capacité de nous de
nous adapter voire de prendre les
devants sur un certain nombre de de
une dernière
sujet moi c'est juste un sujet il va
falloir aussi que les ceux qui
représentent l'état dans notre
département est un discours très clair
sur la cité je vais vous donner un
exemple qui va vous heurter mais qui m'a
heurté mais je me suis calmé nous avons
une nouvelle préfète à l'égalité des
chances dans mon département qui a qui a
pas dû regarder qui j'étais parce
qu'elle n'a pas dû comprendre qu'elle
disait mes combats depuis longtemps elle
est osé me dire vous savez dans
certaines de nos villes il faut qu'on
fasse accepter la laïcité par des modes
par des moyens détournés
des moyens détournés
donc c'est une représente de l'État qui
ose dire ça parce que la laïcité ne
s'impose pas en tant que cité il faut
trouver des moyens détournés pour un
pour que les jeunes acceptent la laïcité
dans les collèges et les lycées et je
n'ai pas osé lui demander ce que c'était
des moyens détournés mais de la part
d'un préfet à l'égalité des chances ça
me choque je vous le dis tout de suite
puisqu'on est un petit peu sorti de
l'épurement commission des lois
et qu'on a abordé les problèmes de
d'enseignement effectivement parier de
l'enseignement en famille il y avait une
crainte d'un certain nombre de familles
que éventuellement dans certains
départements où l'éducation nationale
n'aurait pas les moyens d'aller faire
tous les contrôles du coup il refuse
plus l'enseignement en famille est-ce
que vous avez des remontées est-ce que
vous avez le même taux d'enseignement en
famille ou pas est-ce que vous pourrez
avoir je comprends que vous n'avez pas
les chiffres tout de suite puisque là on
est comment ça la discussion à bâton
rompu donc
c'est moins préparé mais si vous avez
des éléments effectivement c'est assez
intéressant parce que c'était une
inquiétude et ça permettrait de calmer
certaines inquiétudes de personnes qui
n'étaient probablement pas du tout visé
initialement par ce texte et est-ce que
vous remontent des pressions sur les
enseignants par rapport aux
enseignements je pense aux problèmes
d'éducation sexuelle dont on sait que si
on difficultés contre les violences
intrafamiliales il faut aussi un peu
expliquer ce que c'est que une le
consentement une relation d'égalité
entre les filles et les garçons qui peut
être refusé par un certain nombre pour
des raisons
philosophiques ou religieuses et là
j'inclus de façon assez large puisque
pour le coup
vous savez je m'intéresse pas que à la
religion musulmane mais a aussi
à la religion à des religions
évangéliques qui peuvent faire des
pressions tout aussi fortes sur
l'éducation sur le fait de j'ai entendu
récemment de pas enseigner la
préhistoire bah oui on sait bien Adam et
Eve donc forcément après histoire c'est
quand même assez bizarre et oui oui donc
il y a alors est-ce que vous avez des
remontées de ce genre et effectivement
est-ce que il y a de votre côté pour
pouvoir accompagner l'éducation
nationale à une façon de renforcer et de
sécuriser ses professeurs parce
qu'effectivement notamment je le sais
sur l'é ducation sexuelle s'ils le font
pas c'est soit parce qu'ils se sentent
pas à l'aise soit parce qu'ils ont peur
d'avoir des problèmes avec les parents
madame la ministre
merci à la présence sur le sujet de
l'UEF je vous donne les chiffres que
j'ai s'ils sont insuffisants on les
complétera donc je l'ai dit dans mon
propos introductif mais on a eu on avait
67000 enfants qui suivaient une
instruction en famille on en a 53000
aujourd'hui donc une baisse de 27 %,
mais environ seulement 10% des demandes
qui ont été refusées sur la base des
dispositions de la loi CRR mais si vous
voulez des détails plus plus précis
éventuellement vous nous direz lesquels
et on voulait fournira bien évidemment
sur la question des atteintes à la
laïcité alors c'est vraiment l'éducation
nationale qui a cette qui a l'ensemble
du du spectre ce que je peux vous dire
dans les éléments qu'on a c'est que ça
concerne toutes les disciplines vous
avez parlé d'éducation sexuelle et de la
préhistoire mais ça concerne également
la musique
ça concerne toutes les disciplines
vraiment donc il faut pas imaginer que
voilà ça concerne que le cours sur les
religions ou que la philo sur c'est pas
la réalité donc ça concerne toutes les
disciplines c'est la raison pour
laquelle
notre rôle au ministère de l'intérieur
c'est la partie formation c'est à dire
comment on accompagne les enseignants
pour faire face à ces situations de
refus d'un élève de devoir telle ou tel
partie d'enseignement enseigné comment
comment on réagit à ça qu'est-ce qui
mérite un signalement qu'est-ce qui
comment on traite les sujets ça c'est
notre rôle ensuite si à l'éducation le
reste est à l'éducation nationale donc
je crois que dans le travail
éventuellement vous mènerez avec la
commission de la culture ça mérite
effectivement peut-être d'avoir de
creuser ces sujets là notre rôle à nous
s'arrêtant d'une part à la question de
la formation et d'autre part au suivi
des atteintes mais mais pas au-delà
merci Madame la Ministre plus
d'intervention
merci en tout cas merci madame la
ministre pour ce point d'étape vous
l'avez dit justement et on nous allons
laisser nos rapporteurs pour suivre
leurs travaux voilà
ça vous reprendrait à la rentrée on
espère bien vous retrouver à la rentrée
pour reprendre les travaux voilà
donc la séance de la commission des lois
et est terminée je vous remercie bonne
soirée